so a somewhat a new game in town is some
so data sets are good for dealing with
data that has a structure that's kind of
basically rows and columns and things
like that if you want to deal with data
that's basically enter the property kind
of thing we have a new thing we call
entity store which is kind of a user
level way of having something that is
just like the entity property system
that we've that we've been creating for
for a lot of the curated data that we
have and the idea is it's it's it's a
nice thing using you you IDs and so on
to to keep things apart and letting you
build your own sort of private entity
store that you can save in the cloud or
letting you knit together different
entity stores and so on all right so
then and when once you have an entity
store you can store it in a public cloud
and private cloud you can register that
entity store so that you can knit it
together with all of the other curated
data that we have and so on well so I
mentioned I've mentioned data curation a
bunch of times than I've mentioned
different kinds of data curation one of
the ones that's been interesting for us
is image curation and that's been
important in for example a machine
learning technology stack I showed one
example earlier of our image
identification system something we
brought out early last year actually
there's a consumer website that's based
on it see here we can just go to image
identify com and this is a consumer site
people use to go and just drag that in I
can drag in pictures and it recognizes
about 10,000 different kinds of objects
it does a pretty good job now of
recognizing even quite specialized types
of objects it was based on about 30
million images used as a training set
and the main I think our image
identified does rather a lot better than
pretty much anybody else's
general-purpose image identifier
the reason is not particularly the
underlying neuron that technology which
is sort of standard state-of-the-art
technology it's rather that we did a
pretty good job of curating the training
set and again using the same kind of
curation methodology that we've used for
numerical geometric other kinds of of
data sets also being able to curate an
image data set the same kind of
methodology I think what's interesting
about curation from point of view of
many many organizations is that curation
requires kind of judgment at all levels
and the difficulty is how do you a
common difficulty is how do you when
you're dealing with 30 million images
for example how do you actually inject
you know you have to have a combination
of automation and human judgment and how
do you inject the right level of
judgment at the right level in in the
process to get something like that done
in an efficient way well actually in we
just brought out version 11 of our
technology stack and the one of the
things that's new there is a much more
sophisticated capabilities in the neural
network area and the let me try to show
you an example the one of the things
that is is sort of a new frontier of
curation for us is curating neural
networks themselves and curating models
around your own that works so for
example there's a notion of a net graph
and a net graph is a is a neural net
graph and let's take a look um oh gosh
where is there a good one well this is a
very boring neural network graph but I
was looking for a more interesting one
um the oh yeah here we go so so these
are this is a typical neuron that graph
that contains a series of different
operations that are dot plus layers and
softmax layers and other kinds of layers
that you find in neural networks and the
point is that you can take that there's
a what we've been doing is the machine
learning and
deep learning the neural nets and so on
are one of these areas that I probably
seen a dozen times in my life it's an
area that's in hyper growth at the
present time when I when I worked in
physics in the late 1970s particle
physics was in hyper growth at that time
it was was fun to see because there was
kind of a major new result every two
weeks or something which you know
particle physics flatline sometime in
the late 1970s in terms of that that
type of activity but the area where
that's happening today is in machine
learning and neural networks and so on
and so we are we've sort of committed
ourselves to surfing this some
particular period of hyper growth where
there's you know interesting new result
every two weeks and basically the the
next curation frontier for us is taking
every every interesting new neural
network that comes out in all the papers
that are coming out and curating them in
a neural net repository so that we can
provide for people the latest neural net
that you know does automatic
colorization of black and white and
white movies or does some kind of thing
for generating handwriting or or
whatever else and so do that we've got
this underlying system that represents
symbolically the structure of a neural
network it kind of lives on top of the
the standard things like a max net
intensive tensorflow and things like
this and allows you to to construct a
neuron that which will sort of
automatically be be knitted together in
the appropriate way from the symbolic
description so sort of an interesting
area of curation because there's the raw
Network and then there's a trained
network that you have to curate and then
there are features that you get from a
train network so for example an image
identification the sort of step one is
curate the 30 million images step two is
derived feature vectors derive
essentially feature extractors from what
you know when you when you look at all
those things in the world you realize
that there are certain kinds of features
that discriminate between different
kinds of objects and what the system is
doing is learning those discriminations
you can then take those discriminations
and use them
to to identify other images so right now
if you have a specialized image data set
it becomes because we have the sort of
pre curated collection of feature data
that comes from our training of the 30
million images you can then use those
those feature extractors to incredibly
much more quickly trained on some
particular data set that you might have
of pictures of fishes or or the you know
car accident results or or whatever else
and again this is sort of an interesting
area of curation because once got kind
of the raw underlying neural network
which has its complicated structure that
but hasn't been trained it has no
weights associated with it then you've
got various trained neural networks
you've got the feature extractors from
the neural networks and so on um we've
so and the result of that it's sort of a
new kind of building block for
programming because what what we're
expecting is going to happen is people
will take these some these neural net
building blocks and usually when you
write programs you think well what's the
sort of what's the way that this
function produces its results and it
will be glued together with this other
function in the case of this type of
system what you would have is something
which says okay this is a block that
sort of understand something about
images and classifies and there's
another block that generates natural
language let's just take those two
blocks put them together and then train
on finding descriptions of images for
example and this is something that seems
to work rather nicely and where you're
taking this sort of curated blocks of
functionality from from neural networks
and then knitting them together not by
sort of human engineering effort but by
by applying training data and so on okay
so that's so mentioning another another
frontier of data and curation big
project that we've taken on is curating
pure mathematical concept
so there about three million theorems
that have been published in the in the
history of mathematics and we've been
we're interested in representing all of
the knowledge that corresponds to those
theorems it's a it's a big project the
first step of that project is the notion
of something like an entity of you know
this is a species of animal or something
there's no there's no similar notion for
mathematics it's a bit more complicated
than that and let's see if i can find um
see um let's let me just see if I can
find something here um let's see not
sure if that's right um the may not that
may not be something to know doesn't
doesn't know what that is okay so what I
was hoping to show you but realize that
I don't have readily at hand sorry is so
in mathematics the the issue is that one
has to kind of curate the underlying
concepts of mathematics we've done a lot
of that in Mathematica and we've kind of
got we finished the 19th century
completely as far as the kinds of
concepts that you need for mathematics
and we are now the now the challenge is
to cover the whole 20th century and and
beyond so to speak with all of the
mathematical concepts that are needed to
represent all those theorems and so on
and what happens is you have a concept
like a function space let's say and
you'll have various kinds of elaborate
mathematical properties of that
mathematical computations on that and I
think they're about between a thousand
and fifteen hundred of these kind of
mathematical concepts like you know this
is asymptotically equal to that or this
is the you know the homotopy of this is
is that these are kinds of sort of
computational mathematical concepts and
there are probably another thousand or
fifteen hundred over and above what we
already have
in Wolfram language that sort of cover
up to the the present day of research
that's been done in pure mathematics
once you have those concepts within each
of those concepts is then typically a
whole bag of kind of just similar
entities so for example with function
spaces once you have the notion of a
function space then there are 500
different kinds of functions places that
people have studied in the literature of
pure mathematics and so that then
becomes a a more traditional curation
project although it's one way you're
going through text books and papers and
and picking out the the features of
these things from from theorems so that
that's a coming attraction is the the
effort to curate the facts of pure
mathematics another covering attraction
that is still earlier stage of
development is something I've been
working on it current name is a symbolic
discourse language enough that will be
the surviving name but the challenge is
the following so in the morphing
language we've been trying to find
representations of lots of kinds of
knowledge and data in the world and
we've covered you know many different
areas but there plenty of things in kind
of everyday language and so on that
we've not covered we if we say you know
I I want a piece of chocolate okay we
have a pretty good representation of a
piece of chocolate we don't have a great
representation for the I want part of
that sentence so the question is can we
have a precise representation for four
sort of everyday discourse and the
answer is definitely yes and one can
start thinking about it in terms of
nouns and verbs and things like that but
actually what's really at stake there is
sort of the semantics the underlying
semantic concepts okay so I've been
interested in in building something like
that for many decades now and I haven't
really haven't really had a concrete
enough use case to understand what to do
and I think I think now what I've
finally understood is that things like
smart contracts where you're trying to
take for example a you know just as
we're trying to take mathematical
theorems and represent them in a precise
symbolic way we would like to take legal
documents and represent the content of a
contract for example in a precise
symbolic way
that becomes pretty interesting because
you can then do things like
automatically determine whether the
contract has been satisfied things like
this but the challenge first is to
curate kind of the the the concepts of
everyday discourse in such a way that
you can actually and represent that and
so that's something which is a ongoing
effort of mine it's sort of an
interesting area because it's something
where people people tried to do this
than the 1600s you know liveness when he
was kind of inventing some of the things
that became sort of our modern notions
of computation his original idea was to
take legal documents or or and and find
a a precise symbolic representation
using logic for those kinds of things
and there hasn't been that much work
done on this it's kind of a kind of
interest to see what people did in the
1600s I think the world has changed a
bit since the 1600s and that's reflected
in the in the different kinds of
concepts that are important today well
anyway so that's another kind of
frontier of data as far as I'm concerned
is curating the concepts of everyday
discourse for the purpose of creating
things like smart contracts or more
generally in sort of the the emerging
world of AI there's the question of okay
so what do you how do you tell the AI is
what you want them to do and for that
you basically need to be able to
represent all sorts of all sorts of
human things another another curation
effort which we haven't done is curating
the various kinds of ethical and moral
codes of the world I've sort of decided
that's a not as purposeful a project as
one was as one might think but it's
something which we will actually be able
to do in a meaningful way once we have
this symbolic discourse language so and
the thing that's interesting when it
comes to thinking about making
computable things like contracts is one
thing is to represent what the contract
says another thing is to figure out how
you get the facts that determine whether
the contract has been satisfied and in
kind of the world of internet of things
and machine learning and so on
the there are a lot of interesting
sources for that you know is this a
grade a peach or something well they're
a bunch of criteria they're written down
for that but you can make a machine
learning classifier that will take an
image of the thing and with very good
precision figure out you know is this in
fact something which satisfies the
criteria for being a grade a peach or
whatever and that's and so you can
expect to to have to have something
where the input is coming from IOT for
example going through machine learning
going into the symbolic discourse
language and then being and they're
being executed or interpreted
automatically so that sort of brings up
yet another form of curation which is
the curation of a pis and services and
so on and so for example one thing we've
been actively doing is curating
different kinds of external services so
whether it's some curating access to
open library or archive or for example
wikipedia is an easy one you know you
can say I don't know let's say let's get
the this will just by default get the
Wikipedia article on data just for fun
i'm curious what happens if you do and a
um if i just take [ __ ] wikipedia article
for data and make a word cloud out of it
um okay not too surprising but so so
another activity is curating AP is part
of that is dealing with the horrors of
authentication for different kinds of
api's I think we now have a pretty nice
symbolic representation of all different
forms of funky or Thoth indication that
people people use and so on but another
is being able to take the kinds of
things that these api's produce and and
and interpret them in in terms of our
our language and we've been doing a lot
on that something that is a new thing
for us is what we call integrated
services where we're taking something
like for example satellite image data
which a lot of our customers are
interested in and being able to get data
from external service providers running
it through our cloud dealing with
billing kinds of things on behalf of the
the original data provider but providing
it as an integrated part of our language
with from a variety of different
external data providers and that's kind
of a new new thing for us is these
integrated services where we are
handling kind of the distribution of in
in many cases what I think is going to
end up happening is is people who have
data that they have been providing in
some particular market we provide a
mechanism for developers and in a sense
and research consumers and things like
that to get easy access to that data in
a way where we're handling all of the
kind of bureaucracy of what has to
happen and letting that data flow
directly into our infrastructure and
language and so on so that's kind of a
new thing for us well back to more
traditional data okay i want to mention
something that we are soon going to be
rolling out which is a new thing for us
as our data repository and the idea is
to finally make a data repository that
um that really conveniently works for
people and it's some the the notion is
that well you know we can we can take a
look here this has been populated with
some some kinds of things you know um
whatever it is it's it's some I don't
know we could go and look at Tim let's
go back here um so you go here and let's
say I don't know that one sounds fun so
this is a this is data from from NASA I
guess
on fireballs and Bowl ides observed so
now we can just take this resource and
we can go into of language and we can
say let's use that resource so that will
come in like this we can say give us so
we could say show the metadata of this
so we can show the sort of default data
from here and this will come in if the
okay there we go and so this now comes
in as one of our data sets and we could
for example let's say we take that all
comic coordinates oops and so now we'll
get a bunch of these coordinates and now
let's say um what happens if I do this
okay so that's now showing taking those
geo coordinates which have now been the
original data set that this came from
probably had these just in plain text
these have now been turned into our geo
position objects and then the whole
thing can flow through this pipeline to
come in and get computations done on it
so so the idea of our data repository
it's anybody can with within welcome
language you can create a resource
object a resource object is something
that contains both actual content and
metadata that and you can take that
resource object and deploy privately to
the cloud you could take that resource
object and make it a public cloud object
we could say a cloud deploy that
resource object to to the cloud and give
it public permissions for example that
would allow anybody to access that
resource object in the cloud but they
would end up having I mean if I just
take an arbitrary let's just take that
plot 901 and deploy just that particular
plot to the cloud and it will come out
as this thing with this uuid I could go
to the cloud there there that just came
up as a web page this could be an active
thing or it could be an API or whatever
else I just in this particular case just
deployed that that picture to the cloud
but so so anybody can deploy a resource
object to the cloud for use by
themselves or by people that they
specify can use it the you can do the
same thing in a private cloud but you
can also say within the language you can
say resource submit submit that resource
object to us for use in the public data
repository okay so so again it's all
operating within within our language
resource submitted something that
initiates essentially a human process of
curation and it will work kind of like
an app store or or anything of that type
where we will be curating these things
will also probably have an open access
publishing mechanism and then those
things that are accepted will will show
up on with a with a kind of a shingle
here on in the data repository website
and be searchable and exposed to the web
and so on um I think you know we can go
and look at and there's all sorts of
different kinds of data you can put here
because this is just all the data here
is just Wolfram language it's just
representing the wolfman language it can
be it can be images it could be let's
see what is this this is some it can be
text you know this is some however this
is okay presidential nomination
acceptance speeches okay um we could for
example take that as line 104 I'm now
curious and let's take all of those and
say their locations and hopefully those
locations will have been see whether we
can make a plot so that works um okay
there we go um so the idea is you can
you can put any kind of data into the
state of repository and have it be able
to flow through our pipeline so so
um one thing that um I mean the one
thing that some the underlying framework
this underlying symbolic resource system
framework is actually something that can
be used not just for data it can be used
for other kinds of things i mentioned
neural net repository that's another
thing that's coming repository of 3d
parametric objects repository of api's
all these kinds of things work using
this same resource object framework and
it's it's easy then to deploy apps and
things that call things in this resource
system well I thought I would mention
just sort of one one thing that I've
been realizing recently is kind of the
general data pipeline in in our kind of
world the first step is you've got to
have the data has got to be somewhere so
for example you might say here's a piece
of data that's sitting in some CSV file
somewhere on the web and the first thing
you can do is just say okay let's let's
read that data in and how big this is
but but let's just that's just how long
maybe this is a slow network connection
shouldn't take that long okay so this is
this is just raw reading the thing from
a CSV file now within this data this is
data about some kinds of species and
weights and lifespans and all sorts of
other things with species and when you
just read it in from a CSV file you'll
just get a bunch of maybe numbers may be
strings things that happen to be
standard in a CSV file let's just take
the first five of those for example okay
so that's a big messy thing with them
that's that seems to be the header of
the CSV file and then there's various
okay minus 9 9 9 i'm guessing as a
missing data indicator and there's a
39-point 5 which is probably probably
the weight of some kind of bird i would
guess based on the fact that it says ah
raise their butt so this is this is what
you kind of get by doing sort of a raw
import of this data you can also do
semantic import of this data and that's
using our natural language understanding
stack to try to figure out given that
it's seeing a column and it knows
and it can see for example that some
things in that column are places it will
then try and interpret everything in the
column as as places and and we'll do a a
decent job of that but and it gets kind
of messy to go you know we can go and do
computations directly on this but it's
kind of messy so that the next sort of
step in this is to get the data kind of
imported to the point where it is
reasonable where you can put it in a
data repository which means that it in
sort of understood semantically and so
on and so here here's a version of this
same data set that was cleaned up enough
to make it into the data repository and
there and now we can see okay this is
now one of our data sets and it's got
some female maturity whatever in rather
overly precise i would say i doubt that
the bird matures and exhort ever that is
matures in exactly that amount of time
but in any case that's what that's what
came from the data and this is now
something which has been canonicalize to
the point where we could go ahead and
say you know pick out this adult body
mass or whatever it is and we could take
them take that and start making
histograms elberton and so on so it's
sort of the next step is the first step
is kind of the raw csv file reading that
in the next step is sort of semantic
interpretation of that straightening out
you know what kinds of what kinds of
entities these are and so on putting
this in the data repositories that it's
possible to access it in a simple way
like this um kind of the next step is to
turn the things that are in there in two
entities and to make this there's a
version of this where I think that's
been done where this is now set up great
well maybe not um where where this
should have been set up what's that so
again
oh okay well that's always bad if it
have the wrong name it's absolutely
hopeless okay all right let's try one
more thing here um this ok that worked
let's see what happens if i say resource
data of that um okay so this this is an
entity store i mentioned entity stores
before and we can go ahead and say let's
just prepend this entity store to the to
the list of all all entity stores and
now what should happen is that we should
be able to take we should be able to
look for entities that are part of this
that came from this external data we can
treat those entities just like we can
treat some entities from that that are
in our internal curated data so so that
has yeah um so that's sort of the next
step is to take this thing that was
originally a data set and turn it into
an entity store where we've identified
entities and we've kind of knitted
together properties of those entities
and so on um so the next step for us at
least is to take that entity store and
turn it into something that would be
good for Wolfram Alpha so to speak and
so that requires doing a lot of
linguistics on the front end to be able
to access aspects of that of that entity
store and also being able to do
computations on the entity store to
generate output that's that's that's of
interest from that and each one of these
steps so so the first few steps here are
quite quick I mean matter of for a
typical not totally messy thing this is
a matter of I don't know maybe an hour
couple of hours maybe as little as 15
minutes to get to well to get to the
data set stage using semantic import
maybe if the original data isn't too
messy that might take 15 minutes to get
it into an entity store maybe it'd take
an hour or two
depending on how how well structured the
data is and so on to get it to a wolfman
alpha stage is significantly more work
because the linguistic Eurasian steppe
tends to require a lot of human effort
the the kind of setting it up with in
the world mouf a framework takes a lot
more effort once ones dealing with weeks
to an up of time there and then the
final level for us is getting the thing
in too often language as sort of a a
standard part of our of our technology
stack that's as we've realized even much
more work because what's good enough for
Wolfram Alpha sort of drive by use of
something is there's a lot of you don't
have to have the same level of sort of
perfect consistency that you need to
have if you're really going to be
building significant sort of stacks of
computation on top of on top of the data
that you put in and so that's kind of
the the ultimate kind of platinum level
kind of use of data is to get it fully
integrated into or from language and
that's what we've done across a couple
thousand domains of data now but it kind
of gives you a sense that they're these
different steps from the sort of the raw
csv file up through the the semantically
interpretive data set the thing in the
data repository the entity store version
of that too then wolf's mouth aversion
and then finally the Wolfram language
version of that so it's a lot of work to
get it all the way through it's already
very useful even a much lower level so
for example for the data repository I
think one of the things I'm interested
in there is supporting kind of data
backed publication for example research
data I mean there's been a mandate from
in the US and other countries for a
government-funded research to be to have
data that is somehow accessible to the
world the reality is whenever I actually
click on those links that are referenced
by paper it doesn't actually work in
fact I think I have not seen a single
case where I've actually been able to
usefully use the data that's come out
from some some some study or something
so our goal is to make it so that one
can actually have that usefully work
through our data repository and through
the kind of through the sort of growth
automated semantic import mechanisms and
the curation that can be done there so
one of the things that turn to support
data back publication one of the things
that we're doing let me see if I can can
do this while here I can do that um is
some from within our cloud um when you
take a let's go here um oh gosh the so
if you create a notebook within our
cloud and you say i'm going to have
something that is i don't know the plot
of them let's make just a you know a
table of prime numbers or something here
um I got a table of 100 primes or
something and now let's say let's make a
list plot of those not very exciting but
now if i say i want to deploy that
deploy that result and i deploy that and
i say give it a source link and give it
an automatic source link okay so that
will now deploy this particular thing
and it'll come out as some some page
here that just has oh that's because i'm
the owner of the thing okay it would
have looked a little different if I'd if
I'd if somebody other than me had been
looking at this because I would no
longer be the owner there let's get rid
of those sample tigers that I was using
for image identification so what you'll
see down here and it would it would also
appear if this was an embedded graphic
inside a paper or something you'll see
this thing that says source notebook and
so you can go to that source notebook to
go and find how did you where did that
plot come from and so then you'll find
you'll go to an active notebook where
you can recreate the plot and so a
typical pipeline would be there's data
in the data repository the data in the
data repository is taken and turned into
some cool visualization for example
within a notebook then the that
visualization is deployed to the to the
to the cloud to the web as just a
picture but it has a source link
associated with it when you click that
source link you go to the notebook that
shows how that visualization was created
and that notebook then references an
item in the data repository that gives
you the underlying data and so that way
you can actually you can reproduce you
can say that picture in this paper i can
actually reproduce that for myself using
that that notebook that i found from the
source link so i think this is an
interesting i'm really really useful i
mean i would have used it as ilion times
if papers had come with with those kinds
of source links that actually allow one
to to reproduce the the results in the
paper so it's sort of a true version of
open data where it's not just his a blob
of data it's rather here's actually data
that one can guarantee be able to use
because right here is an actual use of
it that you can actually just run in the
cloud um well there are many many uses
for for all this kind of data one thing
that's been interesting recently for us
is on the one hand we've had lots of
sophisticated organizations from the
Silicon Valley startups to very large
companies and so on using our knowledge
based language to build all sorts of
interesting things kind of the other end
of the spectrum is people who are just
starting to learn about computation
programming computational thinking we've
got quite a big initiative going in in
teaching computational thinking to kids
using our technology stack and sort of a
unique moment because people talk about
teaching coding and programming coding
and programming sort of specialized
engineering activity where you're
learning how to specifically tell
computers how to do particular things
it's not very well connected to random
other things that kids learn in there
you know history class or geography
class or language arts class or whatever
else with our language with all the data
and knowledge that's in the language we
can really connect
the we can really actually focus on
computational thinking rather than on
the mechanics of of coding and we can
bring in all these kinds of knowledge
that that people are the kids are
learning about elsewhere and so it's
been sort of an interesting process to
to figure out how do you teach
computational thinking to two kids and
it's kind of a analogous to the thing
that everybody kind of knows is
important which is teaching mathematical
thinking and the whole kind of you know
stem and mathematics direction there's
been a thousand years to figure out how
to teach mathematical thinking to kids
we're kind of at years 0 for teaching
computational thinking two kids and I've
been personally quite interested in what
the best way to do it is I wrote this
book which is a book that seems to be
getting used a bunch by adults but I
kind of wrote it mostly for kids it's a
it's a it's a book for that assumes no
knowledge of programming and no
knowledge of math basically and gets to
the point where you can deploy a cool
web apps and so on that make use of
serious serious computation the that
book is available free on the web and
it's and there's a thing called wolf in
programming lab which is kind of a
wrapper around that book and other
activities intended for sort of self
service learning of computational
thinking but the thing that's
interesting there is just seeing seeing
all of this knowledge based programming
knowledge based computation that we put
so much effort into and and that has
become widely used in kind of the
research and development community also
being sort of automated to the point
where it's readily accessible to kids
and I think it's it's a pretty
interesting thing because it really what
we see in practice is kind of a a very
diverse collection of teachers and kids
who who are not necessarily the the
geekiest most technical most mathy or
whatever becoming attracted to kind of
this kind of knowledge-based computation
and computational thinking and I think
that's a fairly interesting direction a
really interesting place for foot forum
for this to go i'll just show you one
amusing example this is a person who was
11 when she contacted us I think she's
now a much older at age 12 but this is a
post from a kid who lives in New York
about some using often language to to
look at open data provided by New York
City about I think this is about car
accidents which I find amusing because
she's several years from being able to
drive um but the that's some what does
she have here but what's interesting
here this is just simple often language
code as written by a twelve-year-old to
go and take New York City data and do
things with it and it's kind of cool
that this that this type of thing is
possible for for kids to do at this
point and it's kind of a nice place to
see um kind of the the data that a lot
of us putting so much effort into
curating and so on being made available
to the future generation so to speak
well it's it's some this whole direction
of computational thinking part of the
reason i think that computational
thinking is is such an important thing
in the world is because sort of all
these different fields are moving in a
computational direction and kind of my
statement about kind of the future of a
lot of intellectual kinds of things is
think about all the different fields
that people study from you know
archaeology to zoology and then imagine
there that field is called X and then
prepend the word computational to the
name of that field so you have
computational archaeology through
computational zoology and the
interesting thing is that either
computational X for every X already
exists or it's going to exist and pretty
much every one of those computational X
things is defining the future of the
field of the field X so to speak
and I think that's some to me that's
kind of the most most interesting thing
that's happening as a result of all the
work that that we're doing on on data
and curating data and so on is enabling
these computational X for all X and one
of the things we're doing to sort of
think about the things that we do is
doing more and more with all the
different kinds of computational X is
and in fact the when we look at the this
conference for example one of the things
I find interesting is sort of picking
out the things that are the precursors
of computational X that we're seeing in
in different kinds of data that people
are working with and so on and actually
I think in the in the future of this
conference we're definitely going to be
going in that direction emphasizing
emphasizing sort of computational X for
all X instead of emphasizing very much
the content of data that we're working
with them and the purpose of getting
that data as a way to enable a new new
fields to arise that are the sort of
computational analogues of all existing
fields and so for me this kind of
general approach of computational
thinking this availability of
knowledge-based computation it's
enabling this these new directions which
I think are really important for both
the intellectual world on the practical
world going forward and I think I should
stop there so thank you very much